wer hätte das noch vor wenigen jahren
gedacht die europäische union steckt in
einer bestandsgefährdenden krise an
ihren grenzen werden zur abwehr
millionen starker flüchtlingsströme neue
mauern errichtet aus der sicht meines
heutigen gastes parag khanna ist das
eine bedauerliche entwicklung vor allem
weil wir der gesamten westlichen welt
ein wiedererstarken des nationalismus
und damit der globalisierung skepsis
erleben wie sind diese dynamik um zu
begreifen wie zu bewerten ist die vision
einer friedlichen mannigfach vernetzten
welt ohne nationale grenzen wirklich nur
ein utopisches hirngespinst oder nicht
vielmehr der einzige wahrhaft gangbare
weg in eine bessere zukunft
ich bin sehr froh diese fragen mit einem
der führenden globalisierungs
theoretiker weltweit besprechen zu
können parag khanna sie sind
politikwissenschaftler politikberater
für regierungen in asien in nordamerika
und nicht zuletzt auch bestseller autor
ihr jüngstes buch connector graffy legt
eine neue weltkarte ein neues
verständnis für unsere welt aus
herzlich willkommen vielen dank herr
karner in vorbereitung auf diese sendung
haben wir zweimal miteinander gesprochen
am mittwoch habe ich sie in sydney
erwischt am donnerstag in singapur
heute sind sie hier in 72 stunden einmal
um die welt ist das eine normale woche
irgendwie gewusst und ich hatte die von
dieters telefon sogar an im flugzeug
das ist für sie eine ganz normale woche
im leben in der tat ja anders sind für
man sich zu hause auf jedem kontinent
und auch in den spielen auf dem flug
zwischen den kontinenten auch wenn
jemand in deutschland und der schweiz
wie sie ist und er spricht so gut und
flüssig deutsch wie sie dann ist die
erste frage meist und woher kommst du
eigentlich
woher kommen sie eigentlich und was
halten sie eigentlich von dieser frage
also man kann also ich bin in den
gebäuden also und in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten aufgewachsenen dubai
bzw in new york zum teil dann weil
schüler in deutschland für ein jahr als
austauschschüler das war 1994 95 und
wieder in berlin als aus der student an
der freien uni berlin inzwischen war ich
an der
in den usa und promoviert in london und
inzwischen sind wir nach zügiger
vorgezogen also wo komme ich her ich
sammele die identitäten überhaupt
globale existenz also wenn man ständig
reist und sich in neue kontexte ein
findet dann braucht man vor allem eines
karten haben orientierung geben sie sind
ein großer kartenleser und liebhaber
fangen wir doch mal mit einer karte der
welt an nämlich der ebstorfer weltkarte
was sehen sie wenn sie diese karte der
gesamten welt sehen aus dem jahre das
1300 ich sehe aber glaube ich sehe hier
eine karte der vergangenheit wo
natürlich unsere religiösen glauben
unsere eltern schon geprägt hat mehr als
die geografische realität wir haben
versucht und wirst du versuchen
natürlich immer die wird einzuordnen
nach unseren nach unserer eigenen
glauben und im zentrum dieser weltkarte
ist tatsächlich jerusalem
oben ist der osten oder drückt uns das
paradies und links unten europa das
heißt es ist gar keine karte die
irgendetwas abbildet sondern die eine
heils ordnung zeigt die kreditkarte wie
sie wissen ist eigentlich die älteste
puppe kann der organismus oder methode
und die ist es auch immer noch und wie
gesagt es war also im bewusstsein haben
wir immer gesucht nach einem mittel um
serbe die welt verständlich zu machen
und das tut es immer noch und nicht nur
ein geografisches verstanden das haben
wir besucht aber auch dann ein geistiges
verständnis so steht jede karte für eine
weltanschauung da geht ein bild der welt
und sie haben sich nun den letzten
jahren ganz besonders mit neuen
weltanschauung neuen karten beschäftigt
schauen wir uns mal die parag khanna
version der welt an
das ist die eine karte und da kommt
jetzt gleich eine zweite ebene die wird
darüber gelegt solche animationstechnik
gab es nicht im 14 jahrhundert
und jetzt kommt die dritte genau
und das ist die welt wie sie charakter
kann sich selbst und anderen erklärt was
ist das was sehen wir hier das ist die
weltkarte der konnektivität und wir
haben die drei fundamentales für
fundamentalen also die erste war
transportmittel beziehungsweise
eisenbahn autobahn und so weiter dann
kann das ist das rot das ist ja auch das
rot und grün ist wahr ist lexisnexis
leitungen zum beispiel also energie und
natürliche öl und gaspipelines der und
die dritte zwischen bevor vor allem über
beziehungsweise unter den ozean sind die
internetkabel das sind wir ja auch
kommunikation also transport energie
kommunikation sind die drei bereiche der
infrastruktur was uns alle verbindet sie
sagen sie wollen den menschen eine neue
vorstellung davon geben wie das leben
auf dieser erde zusammenhängt und sie
sagen diese drei punkte sind die dinge
die wir beachten wir sind darauf kommt
es an
genau weil das sind die infrastruktur
die uns alle verbindet und die haben
diese layers haben wir über die
jahrhunderte aufeinander aufgebaut und
die sind längerfristiges und großen teil
als viele staaten heute nehmen wir mal
die arabische welt was eigentlich
auseinanderfällt
die ölpipelines die es seit siebzig
achtzig jahren gibt werden überstehen
und leben wo die staaten eigentlich
auseinander fallen also wir sollten
eigentlich bewerten welche funktionen
diese infrastruktur spielt in der
menschengeschichte und was mich dazu
motiviert hat diese ganzen karten zu
erzählen und zu malen und digital
herzustellen war die die suche nach
nicht nur nach einer weltanschauung der
konnektivität aber da unsere
weltanschauung er durch begrenzen und
staaten geprägt worden ist und das ist
natürlich nicht die das ganze bild das
ist hier ein genaueres bild ein
präziseres bild das uns auch besser
orientierte handeln
eine ganz alte weißer der geografie
heißt geografie schicksal relation und
sie sagen das ist genau der große
denkfehler unserer zeit die geografie
ist kein schicksal mehr für uns was ist
denn das schicksal konnektivität
vernetztheit verbund zwei highlights
zeit verbundenheit genau
aber wie gesagt ist baut alles
aufeinander auf es ist
wir haben die natur nicht erübrigt wir
haben noch die karten der natur wo grün
für die für den wahl steht braun für die
wüste und blau für die ozeane ist haben
wir natürlich immer noch die kontinente
die landmassen das haben wir die
geologie zum beispiel ändert sich sehr
langsam
dann haben wir die politischen karten
von grenzen und staaten das ändert sich
auch zu beginn sehr häufig wir hatten
bei der gründung der vereinten nationen
nur 51 staaten heute haben wir 200 also
es gibt nichts es gibt nix permanentes
über die politische karte und jetzt
haben die funktioneller karte und las
ist die karte wo wir sehen die die die
konnektivität die verbundenheit was wir
selber gebaut haben warum sollten wir
nicht malen und auf die karte packen das
was wir selber getan haben
also was wir sehen ist der beitrag des
menschen zu unserem globus tanz genommen
1 ist nun auf dieser karte nicht zu
sehen und das wird jeden der sich mit
geopolitik und mit strategie beschäftigt
wundern nationen grenze sind sie ihn gar
nicht richtig glauben sie man kann die
welt ohne nationen grenzen überhaupt
verstehen die sind sehr wichtig aber
geopolitik ist nicht der kampf zwischen
staaten geopolitik ist das verhältnis
oder die beziehung zwischen raum und
macht und es können kunden ganz viele
welche natur dieser macht haben dass
sein terroristengruppen religiöse
religiöse einheiten firmen unternehmen
und auch staaten städten auch also
starten und leiche natürlich in im laufe
der menschengeschichte haben große
imperien eine wichtige rolle gespielt
als nationalstaaten wie wir sie heute
kennen also insofern sollte man
agnostisch sein gegenüber dem wesen des
akteurs es kann ein staat sein es kann
eine stadt sein es kann ein unternehmen
sein usw
die wichtig ist dass wir merken dass die
macht wird sich ausgedehnt und geübt
durch oder durchgesetzt
über die konnektivität sie sagten zwei
grund fällt in der raum und macht warum
müssen wir denken und konnektivität
schafft die verbindung sie ist die
brücke über die räume in der sich macht
verteilt und das verlieren wir aus dem
blick wenn wir an nationen grenzen denn
wir nur an grenzen denken weil wir
denken dass staaten nur ihren eigenen
raum schützen wollen und innerhalb der
eigenen grenzen aber wie gesagt im laufe
der menschengeschichte haben sich große
empfehlen sich immer versucht sich zu
erkennen sind
und die haben sie das gemacht über die
infrastruktur nehmen wir mal die das
römische leichte also die die die
eigentlichen die ersten fahrten oder
oder straßen die weit über den reichen
ausgesteckten wahlen im in der römischen
r und das britische imperium hat dir das
die eisenwaren benutzen um das den
deichen zu erzielen und jetzt heute
china mit der neuen bank asiatische
infrastruktur investmentbank die
erstrecken sich china erstreckt sich
durch die infrastruktur die armee von
china macht eigentlich keine keine
eingriffe in den nachbarländern sondern
es baut straßen baut eisenbahn es baut
existenz das klingt jetzt natürlich sehr
unschuldig aber sie haben ja selber
eigentlich dass eine marktstrategie eine
dominanz strategie sind also diese
strukturen letztlich die neuen armeen
die auch andere länder verzichten oder
versklaven sollen dies sind macht
führungen
das sind nicht angehen aber so
bauarbeiter als typen so konnte man das
eigentlich sehen es ist auf jeden fall
die tatsache oder das ergebnis davon was
jetzt passiert ist dass diese staaten
von zentralasien beispielsweise diese
diese ex sowjetischen republiken von
central china untergeordnet werden
und das ist übrigens jetzt ein sehr
passendes jahr das zu diskutieren weil
der serval der zerfall der sowjetunion
war knapp vor 25 jahren
jetzt konnten wir schauen einfährt ein
vierteljahrhundert danach was die
machtverhältnisse in genau diesen
zwischenraum sende und wir sehen keine
besondere bewegung der nähe
wir sehen die bewegung und die
investitionen in die infrastruktur
kraken der konnektivität achtziger jahre
gestreckt werden
sie sagt 1989 in der tat ein
schlüsseldatum für sie für meine
generation für unsere aber es ist so
wenn man die letzten jahre und sie haben
sehr viel über die europäische union als
beispielhafte staatengemeinschaft
besprochen wenn man sie die letzten
jahre beobachtet der nationalismus ist
zurück die eu baut wieder grenzen setzt
auf grenzen
wie beurteilen sie diese entwicklung der
letzten jahre wir müssen sehr klar sein
in dem vokabel in dem wortschatz in den
definitionen grenzen waren immer da und
mein argument ist eigentlich dass jene
grenzen wir haben desto grenzenlose wer
die welt weil wir werden alles etwas
abhängiger voneinander dass der kleine
der staat desto mehr ist dieser staat
von der westen abhängig muss handeln
muss ressourcen bekommen usw
je mehr grenzen wir haben desto
grenzenloser wird die welt das ist ein
interessantes paradox desto
konnektivität der dass also die welt
braucht immer mehr konnektivität weil
jede jede gesellschaft braucht mehr
konnektivität um zu überleben muss mehr
handel nehmen wir einfach nahrungsmittel
jede stadt der welt importiert mehr
nahrungsmittel heute als vor fünf jahren
vor zehn jahren von zehn jahren weil wir
alle nicht nicht nur weil wir leichter
werden und kunden konnten mehr
konsumieren aber auch weil staaten
keiner werden also durchschnittlich muss
mehr 1 1 eine große importquote die muss
ich den ja sich erhöhen ja also deswegen
dieses paradox also ich stehe nicht für
eine grenzenlose welt ja ich stehe
eigentlich für eine welt mit den mit dem
mit dem absolut mussten mit der größten
anzahl der staaten weil dann haben wir
dann hat jeder stamm sozusagen den
eigenen staat und muss miteinander in
frieden leben und die grenzen sind dass
er definiert also jetzt zu europa
es ist nicht das grinsen wieder erhöht
werden sondern dass es gibt einfach mehr
leitungen und eine grenze ist eine
leitung es ist nicht eine mauer wir
haben sehr wenige mauer jetzt
aufgewertet und auch wenn ein zaun
gebaut wird zwischen zwischen können
sind nehmen wir zum beispiel dass man
auch dann vorüber gingen seien nicht
permanent das heißt nicht dass alle
leute dann dann blockiert sind über
diese grenze hinaus
es ist auch eine reaktion auf die
tatsache dass es so viele menschen
strömungen und flüsse gegeben hat also
wer das eine reaktion darauf ist dann
heißt es nicht dass es nie diese
menschen stimmungen gab es ist nur eine
reibung auf zukünftiger menschen
stimmung aber wir werden doch sicher
übereinstimmen dass diese reibung extrem
zugenommen hat dass sie fast schon
teilweise kriegerische ausmaße annehmen
und das ist etwas was wir uns für europa
auch hier in der schweiz gar nicht
vorstellen konnten in den letzten jahren
jede gesellschaft sucht eine bilanz
zwischen diese leitungen und zuflüsse
und so weiter also damit um stabil zu
bleiben und jede stadt hat dieses recht
natürlich es gibt keine supranationale
organisation jenseits der eu was
migrationspolitik auf ersetzen kann nur
die eu vor allem mit dem schengener mit
dem schengener abkommen hat versucht
diesen liberalismus einzubetten im
völkerrecht ja das ist ein bisschen
abgebaut wird heißt nicht wie gesagt
dass jeder nationalstaat zurückkommen
ist und dass es keine einheitliche
europapolitik ergibt migration ist seit
immer eigentlich die kontrovers ist die
converse dimensionen aber dass schritte
hier an genau ein anderer gedanke finde
ich faszinierend sie sagten jeder staat
begreift dass er alleine ohne verbindung
zu anderen staaten nicht mehr überleben
nicht mehr funktionieren nicht mehr
gedeihen kann
das ist ja auch das argument dass die eu
befürworter immer sagen europa muss eine
geschlossene stimme haben sonst kann es
im globalen kontext sich nicht mehr
durchsetzen und sagen viele in europa
das ist aber schlimm wir waren doch die
weltmacht wir waren doch das zentrum der
welt und sie wollen diese welt nicht in
der sie sich verbinden müssen weil sie
daran gar nicht gewohnt sind und das
bringen
das könnte uns sogar auf die geopolitik
war natürlich in der geopolitik
historisch gesehen oder auch heute noch
das große imperium ist noch wichtig die
usa und nordamerika als ganzes als
friedliche kontinent ist eine säule der
geopolitischen macht china an und für
sich und natürlich in asien asiatischen
raum das ist eine geopolitische seiler
europa ist wirtschaftlich auch noch sehr
sehr wichtig ist es immer noch die
größte binnenwirtschaft der welt wenn
sie einig ist wenn sie getrennt ist dann
ist es natürlich schwache vor nicht nur
intern aber auch dann bei der macht
projektion weltweit unsere generation
meine generation vor allem die alten
europäer sind in einem mindset
aufgewachsen in dem sie eigentlich
natürlicherweise das zentrum und auch
die privilegierten menschen waren würden
sie sagen das ist auch ein grund dass
wir so schwer haben über globalisierung
nachzudenken
bei dir immer noch ein koloniales ein
selbst erhöhen das denken in uns tragen
das mag sein bei einer gewissen
generation aber für junge leute diese
nicht damit aufgewachsen die
kolonialmacht gewesen zu sein die haben
überhaupt keine ahnung davon die wollen
aber auf jeden fall kontakt sein also
verbunden sein das sieht man bei jedem
meinungsumfrage von jungen leuten
weltweit europäer in der chinesin die
haben in sich einen gewissen anteil der
des globalen denken und die die schätzen
die konnektivität die schätzen auch ihre
nationale identität am liebsten beides
haben
also es kann sein dass das obwohl europa
nicht mehr an der macht sei sozusagen
das heißt nicht dass dem abstieg sind
das ist ein großer auch genannten sphäre
was wir immer wieder status angst ist ja
da ja europa ist nicht mehr so wichtig
wie früher
europa ist immer noch also analytisch
gesehen ich weiß welche
meinungsverschiedenheiten um welche
einmal förderliche denken es gibt aber
in der tat ist europa noch sehr sehr
wichtig und sehr sehr stabil vor allem
gegenüber anderen regionen einig was uns
heute stört in europa ist die ist das
instabilität aus den nachbarregionen
importiert werden das ist eigentlich ein
zeichen dafür wie stabil europa ist alle
stürmen hierher verstehe aber was man in
europa nicht glaubt und ich bin ich in
sao paulo bin oder in toronto
europa nicht glaubt ist dass die
nächsten 30 jahre besser werden als die
30 jahre die wir hatten
sie sind jetzt in einer boomregion in
singapur behandelt ist das ein ganz
anderer meint set wird da die zukunft
immer besser das auf jeden fall also in
den gleichen meinungsumfragen wo man
europäer und asiaten und amerikaner
vergleichen würde asiaten stehen
vielmehr für den freihandel und für
offene ganz sind und weitere
globalisierung als die europäer und
amerikaner die merken und europa haben
natürlich mehr profitiert im letzten
halben jahrhundert als alle anderen
regionen und jetzt ist es etwas
gleichgestellter insofern hat man
natürlich ein bisschen angst und
deswegen gibt es den protektionismus
gibt deswegen gibt es in jede region
verschiedene erschienen der politischen
einsätze wo versuch für die korrosion
etwas müssen steuern in die eigene
richtung zum eigenen vorteil und das ist
der wettbewerb in dem wir uns heute
finden wir sagten jetzt es gibt zwei
große entwicklungen eines nennen sie die
evolution das heißt regionen wollen
einfluss für ihre regionalen belange und
das andere nennen sie aggregation das
heißt diese region suchen neue
verbindungen man denkt ja jetzt
natürlich sofort bei der schweiz ist das
so das ist genauso eine regierung genau
die stadt die die schweiz ist eine
städten staat also jedes kanton ist
natürlich sehr autonom
zusammen sind die er wird natürlich ein
kohärentes staat also jedes kanton muss
die eigenen stärken aufbauen hat gewisse
spielregeln sozusagen innehaben was sie
wo womit sie sich bequem fühlen und dann
bauen sie zusammen ein stärker stand ein
starkes und starkem einen starken staat
in europa europaweit ist es eigentlich
ähnlich weil wir haben die regionen die
provinzen haben starten die auch sehr
wichtig sind ohne medaillengewinn bei
turnieren ja die eu hat diese region
ermächtigt in den letzten 25 jahren weil
die haben jeweils einen sitz in
straßburg im parlament die sind die sind
wichtig innerhalb des des staats
innerhalb des landes und die sind auch
wichtig europaweit also europa ist nicht
nur ein bundesstaaten ist auch ein
bundes der provinzen der regionen und
das ist die devise die deformierte
europäische union dafür sind die region
das heißt wenn ich jetzt sage oh gott
jetzt gehen die schotten auch noch von
den engländern weg oder die katalonien
wir spannen dann sagen sie ist doch gar
nicht so schlimm das sollten sie sogar
tue weil der nächste schritt ist immer
gleich die eu-weite ja das heißt die
welt bricht nicht auseinander es wächst
auch zusammen in diesen neuen
konstellation vor allem in den regionen
ja aber für die schweiz stimmt das jetzt
zum beispiel nicht da ist ja kein
eu-beitritt angedacht aber es ist es der
vor zehn jahren muss das gewesen sein
die die eu die vereinten nationen
beigetreten
oder es gibt handel so ness gibt
finanzabkommen es gibt vielerlei
konnektivität also die die exit ist ein
sehr interessantes beispiel
wir empfehlen uns über das paket als ob
die welt auseinanderfällt und bitten
jetzt sich abschottet von der wert ganz
im gegenteil schauen wir uns die die
karte der konnektivität an der
verbundenheit was wir sehen ist dass bin
immer noch eins der top fünf verwundeten
ssten staaten auf der welt ist würde
eurostar zug nicht mehr irgendwie
irgendwie frankreich und und kostet alle
verbindet natürlich nicht die
finanzströme gibt es immer noch die
währung die der wert der werbung ist
noch ein ist wichtiger um die
konnektivität zu bestimmen als die
mitgliedschaft in diesen institutionen
und sie sehen dann für für england jetzt
auch also für das englische königreich
auch eine zukunft die gar nicht
problematisch ist solange die
konnektivität leisten man sollte die
konnektivität des staates zum beispiel
großbritannien nicht daran messen ob sie
eu-mitglieder ist oder nicht sondern wie
connected ist in großbritannien über
insgesamt und da gibt es 20 verschiedene
merkmale oder charakteristik in denen
man das machen kann
aber das ist ja eine interessante sache
weil da kann man ja eigentlich sagen es
gibt einen souveränitäts willen der
völker ja zum beispiel identität waren
die britische und dann gibt es einen
konnektivitäts willen der bevölkerung
die sind aber doch eigentlich ganz
verschieden die ein wollen sich selbst
bewahren und die anderen wollen sich
auflösen in einer krippe
einig wurden die beides und da daraus
entsteht können wir sagen denn die dance
kids so fern ist da raus weil das volk
will auch verbunden sein wie gesagt laut
jede meinungsumfrage wollen die golden
die die völker beziehungsweise die
bürger und die wäre von großbritannien
knackten sein mit der welt das kann man
wollen sie wollen sie
auslandsinvestitionen wollen sie handeln
oder der schweiz genau so genau das
wollen wir aber dann unkontrollierte
migration nein also da daraus entsteht
dann eine gewissensentscheidung ist
musste wo man sagen kann wird wenn wir
control wenn wir unsere
migrationspolitik und wollen dann
mussten wir aus der eu aussteigen leider
das heißt nicht dass wir den wahnsinn
dass der connect der der verbundenheit
mit der wird nicht wollen dass worden
die briten aber das heißt ja auch und
das ist eine konsequenz ihrer weltkarte
das wirtschaftliche faktoren mithin auch
konzern und konglomerate viel wichtiger
für das schicksal eigens einzelner
länder oder regionen sind als es die
regierungen sind das ist ja auch eine
schleichende entmachtung oder
entdemokratisierung des prozesses ja und
nein
wichtig ist dass sie auch dann merken in
wie wichtig die ermächtigung der firmen
ist auch für das volk dies da dieselben
bürger arbeiten auch für diese
multinationalen die sind auch angehörige
der fällt der globalen versorgungskette
und wenn firmen ausziehen würden aus
einem staat aufgrund des ausstiegs des
staats aus der eu aus oder aus einem
anderen freihandelsabkommen dann wäre
schlecht für die bürger also wir so
nicht so leicht unterscheiden zwischen
dem willen des volks und den interessen
der firmen weil die sind etwas näher als
wir glauben
aber wir sind nicht in allen regionen
ganz nah beieinander wir sehen ja in
afrika zum beispiel viele länder in
denen die regierungen so geschwächt sind
so handlungsunfähig dass sie eigentlich
zum spielball von konzerninteressen
werden
das ist schon in der vergangenheit
gewesen es werden nur beste dadurch dass
wir etwas das regierte staaten haben in
afrika ähnlich jetzt nach zwei drei
generationen nach der
entkolonialisierung haben wir bessere
teams in afrika zum beispiel ruanda oder
oder mosambik oder andere staaten aber
gleichzeitig sagen sie es gibt eine neue
form des kolonialismus heute wird nicht
mehr erobert heute wird gekauft heute
wird gekauft durch die versorgungskette
durch globale finanz und zwar aber wir
sind immer gleich gestellte hinsichtlich
diesen marktverhältnissen als vor wir
haben es ist nicht mehr eroberung und
kolonialisierung
es gibt das so wenn beziehungen die
eigentlich betroffenen und geschlossen
werden also das sind entscheidungen die
werden auch nicht demokratisch das sind
aber dann von dem start entschieden
gänge aber glauben sie denn oder ist das
ihr bild das haben sie ja sehr viel
konkreter vor augen ich dass tansania
oder kongo wenn es jetzt um bodenschätze
geht da noch eine souveräne
entscheidungsmacht hat oder wird da
nicht von konzern für diese länder
entschieden nein die haben auf jeden
fall eine souveräne entscheidung und die
die handeln und die spielen sogar mit
verschiedenen auslandsinvestoren um den
besten deal zu bekommen
die frage ist wie die wie dividenden aus
diesen deals er verteilt werden und das
ist eine interne politische souveräne
demokratisch oder nicht demokratische
frage aber da kann man nicht der
globalisierung vorwerfen dass diese
warum diese länder krupp sind die waren
schon immer gehabt die ur version kann
die aber weniger corp machen dadurch
dass wenn die verantwortung haben für
diese für ihre rolle in der globalen
versorgungskette dass es dann gewisse
erwartungen gibt die erfüllt werden
müssen und dadurch erhöht sich der
standard von corporate governance zum
beispiel und manchmal auch die
demokratisierung der staat ist das ist
ein langer prozess
aber wenn wir sehen dass afrikanische
regierungen jetzt besser regel sind dann
ist diese gori sierung ein der vision
gründe dafür aber das heißt ja auch dass
große konzerne in verantwortungs
verhältnisse geraten die staaten ähnlich
sind sie müssen ähnliche fairness
ähnliche gerechtigkeit erwägungen mit
einbeziehen im idealfall die versuchen
auf jeden fall gleichberechtigt zu
werden innerhalb eines staates weil sie
haben eine
roller und erwartungen zu erfüllen zum
globalen markt und deshalb wollen die
natürlichkeit und so weiter damit ihr
interessen geschützt sind weil das sind
nicht nur die interessen des konzerns
sondern auch der konsum der konsumenten
weltweit weil wir alle vernetzen in
diesem globalen markt das was man eine
investition ist und rechtssicherheit
land finanziell druck auf diese dieser
korrupten staaten ihre rolle in der
versorgungskette persische könig ist für
die eigentlich gesund ich muss sagen
auf die dauer das macht die strukturen
in diesen staaten besser umgesetzt
sagten sie ja es gibt ja so eine wippe
eine schizophrenie gerade in europa wir
wollen mehr konnektivität wir wollen
weniger einwanderung oder die
migrantenströme sehen sie denn dass
diese kippe gerade vielleicht in ein
ganz ganz starkes ungleichgewicht gerät
und wie kann man dem entgegenwirken
es ist nicht das erste mal wo wir angst
dafür haben da davor haben in europa
dass es zu viele ausländer gibt ich war
schule im 90er jahre in deutschland ich
habe das gegenüber türken und kurden usw
auch miterlebt inzwischen wissen wir
dass mehr türken glaube ich aus europa
ausreichend zurück in die türkei
richtung gehen genau wie ihre werke als
die schüler in den amerika war habe ich
die das gleiche hobby mexikaner geholt
heute ist es nett 0 beziehungsweise
mexikaner fließen zurück nach mexiko als
in die usa einwandern wenn wir den
politischen und - den politischen
diskurs anhören bzw
donald trump dann hätte man den eindruck
dass nur lateinamerikaner rhein fließen
ohne dass es überhaupt kontrolle gibt
das stimmt eigentlich nicht also es ist
nicht das erste mal wo wir wo wir wie
gesagt unsere über menschen über
flüchtlinge oder einwanderer oberhaupt
die frage ist wie sie sagen wie kann man
das im gegensatz sind vielleicht so
gelassen ich habe eigentlich sympathie
für die stimmen in europa die sagen es
ist zu viel im moment wir sind wir sind
nicht kulturell dazu geeignet oder oder
haben uns nicht kultur eingestellt auch
diese neue realität wir brauchen zeit um
unsere kultur einstellungen und sogar
unser simulations- politik
integrationspolitik zu verbessern und zu
verstärken
und dann längerfristig vielleicht kommen
noch mehr also ich habe eigentlich
sympathie dafür wie gesagt viele werfen
mich vor nur für eine grenzenlose welt
zu stehen
es stimmt nicht jede gesellschaft darf
und muss eine eine bilanz finden und ein
modem oder lackiertes oder ein stabiles
irgendwie vorgehensweise zu finden
ja was sich ganz interessantes wir haben
und wir lesen das über eine welt in
bewegung in eine welt von menschen die
sich aufmachen in ein besseres leben
noch nie waren so viele menschen
qualitativ gerne unterwegs und wir
wissen auch und sie legen darauf großen
wert wohin diese menschen gehen nämlich
in städte genommen die stadt ist
sozusagen das schicksal der
globalisierung innerhalb jede innerhalb
jedes staat auf der welt wandeln leute
in die stadt das auf jeden fall und dann
weltweit gibt es einen kreislauf sowie
von von menschen vom professionellen
oder auch dann auf jedem auf jedem
status oder level der versorgungskette
sozusagen gibt es leute sei dass
bauarbeiter oder putzfrauen oder leute
im finanz ärzte sportler
es gibt immer mehr leute 300 millionen
menschen die jetzt jenseits oder
außerhalb der heimat grenzen wohnen und
die diesen dieser anzahl erhöht sich
eigentlich jedes jahr ja dazu können uns
noch eine weitere carakan karte
anschauen nämlich ja diese karte sagen
sie doch mal was zu dieser karten die es
wieder dazu geneigt eigentlich das
denken über unsere welt ganz und gar zu
verändern schon wieder keine grenzen
wir sind eine stattliche zivilisation
wir sind eine stattliche kultur seit
60.000 jahren wandeln wir um die welt
und wir konzentrieren uns jetzt meistens
in städten an den küsten aber natürlich
in asien gibt es so viele milliarden
menschen die hälfte der menschheit wohnt
in stetten das sind beide in den im
besiedelten gebieten und auch auf den
auf den kosten und die die kreise wie
sie sehen das sind die die megastädte
und es gibt ungefähr 50 mehr ge städte
auf der welt die jeweils mehr als zehn
millionen einwohner haben manche von
denen wie im inneren china chongqing
chengdu in diesem kostet ja da sind weit
über 50 millionen menschen von denen wir
noch nie gehört hat geradezu hier und da
sollte mal weil ja das sind sehr
wichtiger und also geografisch gesehen
diese region nennt sich dieser provinz
nennt sich die shaw new musste und es
ist fast so groß wie österreich ja aber
ist es noch etwas anderes diese kreise
signalisieren wirtschaftliches gewicht
ganz genau wirtschaft und das heißt dass
diese städte als städte oder als
stadtregionen mächtiger sind teilweise
als die staaten zu denen sie gehören
genau und das war was wir hier sehen ist
dass die sind wir wirklich eine
weltkarte und einer zivilisation die auf
staaten gebaut ist oder vor allem aus
der wirtschaftlichen und demographischen
sicht sind wir eine situation der städte
weil die ja die anziehungskraft diese
städte ist nicht nur was menschen
stimmungen angehen sondern auch
wirtschaftlich jedes in jedem kreis gibt
es den kleinen kreis und bei manchen von
denen ist es mehr als 50 prozent der
anteil der gesamtwirtschaft der
binnenwirtschaft was durch eine stadt
vertreten ist normalerweise die
hauptstadt oder das finanzzentrum sei
das jakarta in indonesien indonesien ist
ein staat ist ein land mit 250 millionen
menschen nur 20 millionen von den leben
in der hauptstadt jakarta
die arbeitet mehr als 50 der
binnenwirtschaft bruttosozialprodukt das
gleiche sehen wir bei johannesburg in
südafrika
sao paulo ist ist vielleicht ein titel
der wirtschaft interessanterweise das
sind nicht nur entwicklungsländer wo wir
dieses phänomen beobachten konnten in
großbritannien und dass wir auch in der
in der wechsel war eine sehr wichtige
ein sehr wichtiges faktor london fertig
50 prozent der gesamt britischen
wirtschaft hat das heißt ja auch etwas
anderes zumindest in ihrem mindset in
ihrer idee
heißt die welt soll von städten und
nicht mehr ländern regiert werden
und sie sagen das ist eigentlich gar
keine utopie sondern das war im
mittelalter auch schon so da waren die
städte auch die treibriemen dessen was
dann die globalisierung wurde
wir hätten keine globalisierung ohne die
erfindungen und innovationen im in
hinsichtlich technologie navigation usw
aus der mittel aus dem mittelalter also
der eigentlich ist die globalisierung
vor 1000 jahren im europäischen in den
städten des europäischen rates gebaut
mit dem hanse beispiel mit der
hanseatischen liga und so weiter und
jetzt haben wir wieder eine vernetzte
welt der städte und die welt an staunt
die sichtweise der städte heißt mehr
verbundenheit bauen brücken bauen zu
anderen städten mehr handel mehr talent
merck technologie mehr mehr
flugverbindungen usw
und so sehen so seht die welt die stadt
aber es ist hier so sieht sie die zehn
tracks it und london und das beobachten
wir auch in dänemark finnland in der
schweiz es gibt einen anderen etwas der
stadt als der des landes die menschen
denken handeln führen anders und das
führt zu unglaublichen politischen
abgründen zwischen der stadt und der
landbevölkerung ist das nicht auch eine
konsequenz dieser welt ist die zeigen
dass die länder gleichsam innerlich zu
zerbrechen an dieser differenz
der staat ist mehr abhängig von der
stadt als umgekehrt
und insofern ist die die die führende
die leitende sieber innerhalb eines
staates ist sind das was in der stadt in
der hauptstadt vor allem passiert das
heißt nicht dass sie jeweils das die den
das land sozusagen vernachlässigen
sollen das passiert sehr häufig sogar
das haben sehen wir die ungleichheit
innerhalb innerhalb fast jedem staat der
welt eigentlich also die leute in der
stadt in der abfahrt werden leiche und
der ganze rest bleibt sozusagen
stillstehen und das müssen wir natürlich
mäßigen dass da mussten wir investieren
das ist etwas mehr gleichheit gibt
innerhalb der der binnenwirtschaft und
da durch kunden wir vielleicht
möglicherweise diese
diese spannungen in jeder gesellschaft
überwinden aber was würden sie denn
jetzt konkret an land wie dänemark oder
finnland oder der schweiz raten die so
einen kapital so einen
meinungsunterschied haben wo sie sagen
können die in der stadt wehlen die und
die position die auf dem land die und
die position und die beiden finden nicht
mehr gut und konkret zusammenfinden
keine sprache mehr für ihre bedürfnisse
es gibt natürlich diese zyklen wo dann
gelernt werden wenn jobs dann plötzlich
abgeschafft werden weil ein staat
plötzlicher investition unfreundlich
werden
dann wird in der nächsten wahl diese
werden diesel er sozusagen aufgenommen
und dann geht es dann zurück in die
pragmatische richtung wie es früher war
und das ist auch meine vorhersage für
europa übrigens weil in europa haben sie
natürlich weniger nachwuchs also es gibt
es gibt ja keine nächste generation sie
brauchen einwanderer
sie brauchen sie nur vielleicht
langsamer als wie sie heute einfließen
aber das wichtige prinzip in diesem buch
und in meiner welt anschauen und in der
menschengeschichte ist angebot und
nachfrage
ja und sie haben die nachfrage also weil
sie haben nach nachstellen arbeitsplatz
sie müssen nur kulturell sich dazu
fähigen die deal einzulassen
da kann ja da möchte ich noch mal
nachfragen weil das sehr wichtiges
prinzip ist angebot und nachfrage als
die eigentlichen treibriemen unserer
kultur unserer konnektivität das heißt
eigentlich auch das primat der
wirtschaft vor der politik es ist nicht
so also ich habe das gerade ins im
demographischen zusammenhang erklärt es
ist wirtschaftlich es ist demografisch
es ist naturressourcen wir bauen durch
eine verbundene welt die die möglichkeit
ressourcen menschen technologie geld so
zu verteilen damit dass etwas gleich
verteilt wird jetzt mussten wir unsere
institutionen darauf einstellen dass wir
aus diesen konnektivität vor teilnehmen
um diese politische vision einer fernen
welt herbei zu führen dass wir die
globalisierung an sich nicht leisten die
globalisierung ist erahnen für sich hat
hat sozusagen hat keinen willen wir
mussten eigentlich jetzt dass wir diese
knackte welt gebaut haben
dann kommen wir unserer vision jetzt
einsetzen in diesem sinne müsse die
politik sich entscheiden ob sie
reagieren oder gestalten will oder ob
man dieses verhältnis aus mittelt wenn
jetzt an diesem mega städte denken ja
tokio osaka 100 millionen leute 80
millionen leute los angeles mexico city
und wir denken an globalisierung dann
zeigen sich auch die beiden großen
abgründe der globalisierung in diesen
städten besonders ökologie und
ungleichheit das heißt diese städte sind
auch moloch wenn plätze an den menschen
gar nicht leben sollten oder wollten oft
es ist historisch sind die vielleicht
schlechte gelagert und es gibt viele
ausbeutung der natur
aufgrund unserer urbanisierung und
deswegen will ich nicht deswegen bin ich
nicht komfortabel mit dem mit dem denken
dass es okay ist dass das die mentalität
in der stadt eine in eine richtung geht
und im rest des landes in einer
einrichtung weil in der tat sind die
ökologisch sehr sehr stark und tief
verbunden wasser energie nahrungsmittel
und so weiter deshalb muss nicht
eigentlich sicher besser verstehen und
meine beratung ist immer dass die stadt
ins land immer mehr investiert um in ihr
in der jobs zu schaffen produktivität zu
erhöhen und so weiter und natürlich
diese bilanz mit der natur zu finden
wir sehen das gerade in brasilien
brasilien ist der mit abstand das
ökologisch reichste land auf der welt
und die haben gerade trockenheit in den
städten weil die haben die natur und der
natur welle so ausgebeutet dass das
wasser nicht mehr richtig fließen also
die lösung ist nicht für brasilien das
sao paulo im markt bekommt ganz im
gegenteil die die macht habe in den
städten mussten auf das gesamte
ökosystem denken
schauen wir uns doch mal diese region in
china an von dem sie sagen das wird die
neue mega stadt auf diesem planeten
das sind etwa 100 millionen menschen wir
sehen hier einige dieser mega städte
alle alle in china was ich mich frage
ist das sind 100 millionen leute auf
einem sehr begrenzten
das ist ja auch extrem krisenanfällig
man müsste nur an krankheit denken an
wasserknappheit an wetterschäden gibt es
denn überhaupt modelle dafür wie man 100
millionen menschen auf diesem engen raum
steuert kontrolliert ihnen hilft
eineinhalb milliarden menschen sogar
halt die die auf diese 26 mergelstetten
gebiete verteilt sind und jeweils
natürlich ist das könnte dass kriege
sind fertig sein oder wird china
versucht diese möglichkeit zu überwinden
oder einig einzudämmen dadurch dass sie
in die infrastruktur investieren
das wasser strömt aus also natürlich
gibt es die umstellungen umleitungen der
märkte der wichtigsten flüsse in china
jangtse fluss und und yallo damit alle
städte gut ernährt werden zum beispiel
und dann gibt es die straßen und
eisenbahnen die alle städte vernetzen
und verbinden damit die menschen werden
es gab zum beispiel nach der globalen
finanzkrise 2008 2009 wiesen der arbeits
verluste in südchina jeder bürger in
südchina dürfte aber mit ungefähr sieben
oder acht dollar oder euro ein ticket
kauft nun auf der schnellbahn in eigene
irgendeine andere stadt fahren um einen
neuen job zu suchen und das hat die
arbeitslosigkeit wirklich überwunden
aber sie schildern das jetzt als eine
wunderbare option ich kriege einen 7
euro ticket und kann nach unserer stadt
fahren für einen familienvater bedeutet
dass ich werde gezwungen in einer
anderen stadt zu wohnen vier wochen von
meiner familie getrennt um überhaupt
überleben zu können also diese optional
i tät die sie aufzeigen ist ja auch oft
ein opfer es ist der wirt will in höhe
von den 300 millionen auswanderer
sozusagen oder oder immigranten weltweit
jeder ist eigentlich in dieser situation
in diese lager wir haben so viele
experten
es gibt auch expert expatriates die
dozenten sind von den familien innerhalb
des eigenen landes wir haben auch dann
dafür die wir mit den geldern die dann
zurückfließen von der küste in den
ins lande und auf die anderen gebiete
die ameisen und innerhalb von china gibt
es mehr diese mit ins strömungen als im
ganzen rest der welt zusammen und es ist
dadurch durch dieses opfern was viele
gemacht haben und darunter viele
gelitten haben
aber dadurch hat sich china bereichert
in den letzten zwei generationen also
ich würde sagen dass immer noch eine
netto positiv für alle regionen dass
diese menschen in die stadt gehen ja
aber die wanderarbeiter zum beispiel
sind ja auch ein riesen politisches
problem man kann ja sagen die
flüchtlingskrise in europa ist nichts
anderes als eine wanderarbeiter krise
oder eine angehende wanderarbeiter ist
das international ja und man hört es
gibt auch wieder vorn diese gesetze
diese die nennen sich hugo gesetze was
der was den arbeiter auf das dorf
sozusagen bindet anbindet das wird vor
mir da durch das hat man etwas frei
freiwillige sich bewegen kann wenn ich
jetzt ein sehr ökologisch gesinnten
menschen vorstellen er schaut sich ihre
weltkarte an und sie sagten selber da
gibt es nur menschengemacht ist
ich zeige nur dass menschen gemachte mal
darauf kommt es an der würde sagen das
genau ist das problem an der
globalisierung es ist ein reines gestell
des menschengemachten und es ist ein
ausbildungs und entkernung gestellt für
die natur das heißt all diese probleme
und auch lösungen die sie anstellt
andeuten funktionieren nur über eine
ausbeutung der natur die würden sie da
antworten die überbevölkerung ist
vielleicht das größte problem und es
leiten sich sehr viele andere probleme
da davon da daraus sogar wie korruption
und natürlich mangelt ausbeutung der
natur will sind dabei durch die
urbanisierung sogar die
bevölkerungsanzahl zu kontrollieren wir
haben vor 15 oder 20 jahren vorher
gesehen dass es 15 milliarden menschen
auf der erde geben würde war ungefähr
rund 20 40 gleich sich sogar inzwischen
haben wir das wirklich neue gemessen ist
sollten vielleicht ist werden es werden
nie mehr als zehn milliarden menschen
auf der erde geben
eigentlich ist es vor allem durch die
organisierung wenn vor allem frauen in
die städte einziehen werden die gebildet
die haben zugang zu
zur sozialen dienstleistungen usw und
die familien werden keine also wir haben
eigentlich haben wir das land gewertet
dadurch dass wir über die seelen weil
wir konstant zielen die die
notwendigkeit oder die bürger die gurke
die geografie der des importieren
aber wenn sie jetzt sagen zehn
milliarden menschen in einer
parallelwelt mit riesenstädten mit
maximaler vernetzung und natürlich wir
reden jetzt von asien implizite
versprechen euch wird es irgendwann
vielleicht auch so gut gehen wie uns in
europa ist es ein verantwortliches
versprechen in ihr nur so gut gehen wie
es in europa geht den menschen in europa
geht heißt nicht genauso leben zu wollen
oder oder oder
weil vor allem also eigentlich ist der
bester vergleich mit den usa war nur in
den usa will jeder ein auto kaufen wenn
man ungefähr 10.000 dollar im jahr
verdient in europa ist das anders hier
leicht europäer werden desto weniger
autos wurden die haben eine europäische
städte sind eigentlich das vorbild für
asien war die sind natürlich fußgänger
und die haben natürlich öffentliche
verkehrsmittel und das ist gerade was
europas beitrag zur asien ist
schicken sie auf jeden fall ihre ihre
umwelt können es unternehmensberater
weil sie beraten die asiatischen städte
in dieser nacht haltbare richtung dass
die dass die dicht besiedelt sind dass
die öffentliche verkehrsmittel bauen
dass leute dann über fußgänger seien
also will sich bewegen können ohne autos
zu kaufen und da sehen wir jetzt in
singapur
das sehen wir sogar in chinesischen
städten wo sie versuchen etwas
europäische zu werden deutschland ist
übrigens ein sehr wichtiges vorbild in
jeder dieser hinsicht für china eine
frage die man sich in diesem
zusammenhang auch stellen kann und die
auch für europa wichtig wird können die
maßnahmen auch vielleicht an kurzem
reduktion oder ökologischer reinheit in
einer demokratie umgesetzt werden oder
braucht man dafür vielleicht eine
autokratie gerade mit blick auf asien
könnten sie sich vorstellen dass sie
selber sagen ja vielleicht ist das
autokratisch verantwortlicher umsetzbar
als demokratisch wir haben aufgrund der
über wirkung und der ressourcenknappheit
weltweit also über bevölkerung in asien
und ressourcenknappheit weltweit haben
wir die notwendigkeit und nicht
schneller neu einzustellen auf eine
nachhaltige wirtschaft das heißt nicht
dass wir autokratisch werden müssen wir
mussten schnell entscheiden
die ganzen europäischen gesellschaften
die die am wenigsten konsumieren pro
kopf nach ökologischer sicht sind
natürlich alle demokratien also wird das
heißt nicht dass asien autokratisch sein
muss es gibt auch dann natürlich der den
song der märkte die uns auch dazu führt
es gibt auch regulation es gibt
natürlich den pariser klimaabkommen das
was gerade beschlossen worden ist also
es muss nicht automatisch sein aber wir
mussten sehr schnell wir müssen sehr
schnell nicht stellen werden
aber es ist doch so dass gestehen sie
einen die demokratischen mühlen mahlen
langsam
sie lehrt selber leben in singapur das
ist jetzt kein land das man eminent mit
demokratie verbindet glauben sie
singapur hat an effektivitäts vorteil
es hat auf jeden fall effektivitäts
vorteile aber nicht nur weil es nicht
voll demokratische sondern auch weil es
eine städten statt ist wobei diesen
kreislauf oder feedback club sehr eng
ist und wo man das ergebnis der
politischen entscheidungen sehr schnell
merken und messen und evaluieren
analysieren und neu gestanden neu
orientieren kann und das sollte jeder
staat eigentlich schon kunden egal
welche größe sie ist wenn man sie liest
man hat manchmal das gefühl sie sehen
sie in den menschen als toren politik um
ein soziales wesen das sich verbinden
will das neue verbindung sucht und sie
denken dass man in städten in
stadtstaaten am besten lebt das ist ja
fast könnte man sagen die griechische
version der globalisierung die kann sich
das katholische idee des staates als
statt
ich sehe das genauso ja also es ist auch
vielleicht ein schweizer ideal konnte
man sagen es ist auch dass das uhr
griechischer es ist auch venedig des
mittelalters es ist sansibar in der
kolonialzeit es ist das heutige singapur
je mehr kosten städte oder vernetzte
städte es gibt auf der wert desto mehr
es ist auch die dubai welt anschauen es
ist auch die schnell wachsende stadt auf
der welt es lag immer im geografischen
zentrum der welt ohne wichtig zu sein
nur durch die konnektivität vor allem
über fluglinien emirates airlines usw
ist dubai aufgekommen also dubai teilt
es gibt ja auch noch dass ich war ja
also diese stadt an sich hat eigentlich
sehr wenig öl aber die bundesstaaten
tragen dazu bei dass das leicht geworden
ist aber jetzt hat er seine eigene
weltanschauung und es ist eine sehr
technische welt anschauen die städte die
sie genannt haben die für sie modellhaft
sind die liegen nun am meer und das ist
für ein visionär wie sie ja
wahrscheinlich eine interessante frage
dass mehr was stellen wir mit ihm an
sehen sie in zukunft auch eine
ausweitung der städte auf das meer oder
wird das mehr ein neuer lebensraum für
den menschen werden es ist technologisch
nicht unfassbar dass wir das tun es gibt
der alte unbenutzt ölplattformen die
jetzt neu gebaut werden in städten es
sind leute hunderte leute die auf cruise
schiffen eigentlich wohnen also wir sind
nicht so weit dass so hunderte millionen
menschen plötzlich auf dem auf den
sozialen leben
ehrlich gesagt die richtung in die wir
eigentlich gehen ist das mit dem
klimawandel und mit den
mit den höheren den meeresspiegel
errichtet
das heißt dass wir manchmal dass wir
möglicherweise uns zurückziehen mussten
von den kosten und das wird das ist
möglicherweise das größte risiko was wir
was uns gerade bevor steht in den
kommenden 20 jahren auch da einer dieser
widersprüche einerseits wollen wir
hinaus aufs meer andererseits müssen wir
vielleicht weg von den küsten und das
ist die komplexität all diesen arten
also konnektivität bauen wirtschaftlich
wachsen aber dann rohstoffe wie auspuff
wieder erhöhen und das führt zu den
klimawandel und das heißt dann langsam
dass wir ökologische ein gefährlicher
eine gefährliche welt gebaut haben
er kann sie haben zwei junge töchter
kleinkinder
man fragt sich natürlich was müssen
menschen können die in einer
parallelwelt leben welche identität
welche sprache welche eigenschaften
sollten sie haben ihre identitäten über
am besten mehr identität der sprachen
können
ein pass ist er okay ein reisepass
hollande als er sie überall hin bringt
wo sie wollen natürlich bewegungsfähig
sein und technologisch natürlich
fließend sein meine frau sagt eigentlich
immer dass es keine zwei weltsprachen
wie viele sagen es gibt englisch und
chinesisch
das stimmt eigentlich nicht erlaubt in
der tat gibt es englisch und kohle also
eine technik die die sprache der
technologie ist kohl kunden zu kunden
und englisch zu sprechen sind eigentlich
die 2 welt sprachen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert spricht
man zu hause den technologisch wie zu
hause
also gibt es da schon auf das bedürfnis
eine identität als kulturelle identität
zu wahren und zu preisen weil es sind
das sind auch weit über eine milliarden
menschen inzwischen das ist natürlich es
gibt die kulturelle anziehungskraft und
bei uns natürlich intern sowie wir
aufgewachsen sind nicht dass es bewahrt
werden muss die ähnliche kultur fühlt
sich nicht bedroht wie europäische
kultur es ist so riesig und tief und
historisch geprägt
dass man lernt das nicht weil man das
bewahren muss sondern weil man das
feiern sollte so ist das glauben sie
sehen sie den menschen als ein wesen der
auf den begriff heimat leicht verzichten
kann
nein man kann einfach die den
heimatbegriff irgendwie ergänzen und und
die die hi mate sammeln wie ich sie
eigentlich nur nicht dass es ist eine
rein
es ist ein ergebnis des starts des der
europäischen des europäischen staats
bildungsprozess des 17 18 jahrhunderts
dass man auf diese schlussfolgerung
gekommen ist oder auf dieses
conventional wisdom das heimat nur ein
ort sein kann das stimmt aber nicht
glauben sie das ist eine unterscheiden
ob man denkt ja viel über die
unterschiede asien europa nach würden
sie sagen es gibt ein anderes
asiatisches verhältnis zu dem eingriff
heimat als ein als europäisches also
asiatische staaten haben auch daniel
sehr tiefe 1000 jahre alte kulturen es
ist viel diverse als europa übrigens
also asien die das asien was jetzt
zusammen wächst besteht aus menschen aus
mir mal und indien und china und japan
und korea das sind viel englisch und
linguistik und historisch 4 oder auf
einem viel breiteren geografischen
umfeld heißt es ist viel diverse als
europa die aufgabe ist viel größer asien
zusammen zu bringen und nicht das sieht
man in der jungen generation in asien
dass sie sich auch jetzt überall bewegen
übrigens ist es sehr wichtig zu stellen
dass das was europa was in europa gerade
abläuft bzw
grenzen bringen leitungen zu menschen
strömungen erhöht das steht das spricht
nicht für die ganze welt in gleichen
jahr letztes jahr dieses jahr wo europa
wagt der schengener abkommen zu
zerreißen gibt tipps frei bewegungen für
700 millionen bürger von asien asien die
also die zehn ländern von südostasien
habe im gleichen jahr beschlossen
frey bewegungen zu beschließen das sind
die das sind 700 millionen menschen die
europa als 600 millionen menschen
gleichberechtigt sein sollten also
europa muss auch dann über den
tellerrand hinausschauen das was sie in
europa abspielt ist nicht dasselbe
schulter sind aber es spricht nicht für
die ganze werden auch nicht was in
amerika passiert die ganz große mehrheit
der menschen wohnen eigentlich in asien
und dort gibt es mehr offenheit als
schleuser als als irgendwie ja ganze
aufbau her kann ich muss bei ihnen immer
an den philosophen ludwig wittgenstein
denken wir seien
das denken beginnt mit der frage ich
kenne mich nicht mehr aus sagte sollen
eine karte mal von der stadt in der wir
uns verlaufen haben dann die wir wissen
wohin wir gehen können ich danke ihnen
sehr dafür dass wir uns heute neue wege
gezeigt haben vielleicht sind das wege
die wir sogar vorgehen wollen und werden
und finde es schön dass sie heute bei
uns waren vielen dank hoffentlich auch
ein bisschen freund nächste woche
spricht barbara bleisch mit der
niederländischen schriftstellerin conny
palmen
sie wird sie fragen ob es die wahre
liebe überhaupt gibt ob diese in einer
zweier kiste platz findet und wie man
überbordende radikale leidenschaft
aushält und in der sternstunde kunst
sehen sie jetzt gleich einen film über
die pianistin alice herz sommer viel
vergnügen damit
[Musik]